[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا مشاهدينا يوم انتخابي تنافسي ساخن
عاشت تركيا انتخابات رئاسيه وبرلمانيه
محوريه هي الاكثر اهميه في تاريخ تركيا
الحديث الممتد على مدار 100 عام انتخابات
تقرر ما اذا كان اردوغان سيواصل حكمه بعد
عقدين من الزمن ام اذا سيرسم المنافس
الشرس كالجدار اوغلو ملامح الوجه الجديد
لتركيا وسيجلب الرابع لها كما يعد منذ
ساعات الصباح الاولى حشود من الناخبين
خرجوا الانتخاب الرئيس الثالث عشر
للجمهوريه ولتجديد اعضاء البرلمان وهذا
واد لا نحو
87% من الناخبين المسجلين باصواتهم عبر
191,84
صندوق في ثلاث في 973 قضاء بعموم البلاد
كان اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين ناخب من
المغتربين الاتراك ادلب باصواتهم في المم
الخارجيه لدى 73 دوله والتي انتهت تصويت
فيها يوم التاسع من مايو الجاري اردوغان
قال ان عمليه التصويت تمت بما يلي قبه
الديمقراطيه في تركيا وان الوقت حان
للتشبث بصناديق الاقتراع والاستمرار في
حمايه اراده الشاب حتى صدور النتائج
النهائيا كما اكد نائبه فؤاد اكتاي ان حزب
العداله والتنميه الحاكم سيحترم نتائج
الانتخابات ايا كانت اما مرشح المعارضه
رئيسي كمال كلتشدار اوغلو فقد قال ان
الجميع مشتاق للديمقراطيه مؤكدا ان
الربيعه سيعود لتركيا وسيستمر الى الابد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الرحمن
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا طبعا كنا نتحدث عن ما مجموع
اصواتهم او سينتخبون عبر 191 صندوق اقتراع
سنقف على تفاصيل اولا هذا اليوم مع
زملائنا من اسطنبول العربيه طاهر بركه من
انقره مفردات العربيه فاطمه فهد ومن قهرما
مرعش موفد العربيه غسان ابو اللوز زملاء
الاعزاء احييكم اولا موفقين ثانيا الى هذه
التغطيه مستمرون دائما معكم لالتقاط اخر
الاخبار معكم وسابدا من اسطنبول معك طاهر
طاهر يوم كان نسقه شديد السرعه في الواقع
لمتابعه اولا فتح صناديق الاقتراع فيما
بعد التصويت الان عمليه الفرز مستمره كيف
هي التفاصيل من عندك
اهلا بك يا ريم اهلا ببقيه الزملاء وكل
المشاهدين الارقام وصلت الان الى اكثر من
45 بالمئه فاصل سبعه من الصناديق التي تم
فرزها فيما يتعلق في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
نتحدث عن 52 بالمئه فاصل ثلاثين للرئيس
اردوغان مقابل 41% فاصل 82
مقابل
5.34% لسينان اوغان اما المرشح المنسحب
محرم انجي فحصل على 0.54 في المائه هذا
بعد فرز 45% من الاصوات فيما يتعلق
بالانتخابات الرئاسيه اما فيما يتعلق
بالانتخابات البرلمانيه ووفقا للتحالفات
الانتخابيه بعد فرز 20% فاصل سبعه من
الصناديق فتحالف جمهور الذي يضم الحزب
الحاكم والحركه القوميه بزعامه
بزعامه فاتح اربكان والاتحاد الكبير حصلوا
على 57.6 بالمئه مقابل تحالف الامه الذي
يضم حزب الشعب الجمهوري المعارض وحزب
الجيد فحصل على
28.9 بالمئه مقارنه بتحالف العمل والحريه
وعلى راسه حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي او
اليسار الاخضر بثمانيه فاصل خمسه بالمئه
اما الاجداد فواحد فاصل اثنين بالمئه هذه
اذا النتائج الاوليه وغير الرسميه هناك
بعض التراشق الكلام الذي بدانا نسمع عنه
خاصه يعني من المعارضه فيما يتعلق بهذه
الارقام التي تعلن من الجهات الرسميه خاصه
وكاله انباء الاناضول والتي تتشابه
ارقامها مع ما يعلن هنا في مقر حزب
العداله والتنميه في اسطنبول ويمكننا ان
نشاهد هذه الشاشه العملاقه ريم التي تنقل
الارقام وصلنا اذا الان كما قلنا الى
45.70 بالمئه
النتيجه تقدم الرئيس اردوغان مقابل كريتش
دار اوغلو ولكن هذه نتائج دائما يمكن ان
تتغير شيئا فشيئا نرى المنصه التي سيتحدث
عنها مسؤول وحزب العداله والتنميه الليله
ممن هم موجودون هنا سليمان سويلم وزير
الداخليه نعمان قرطرموش نائب رئيس حزب
العداله والتنميه على صعيد تركيا ونائب
رئيس حزب العداله والتنميه في اسطنبول
عثمان نوري
هذه القاعه مخصصه للاعلام ولتلقي النتائج
من قبل الحزب ويمكن ان نشاهد الكثير من
وسائل
العربيه والعالميه والمحليه التي تنتشر
هنا بصحفييها بمراسليها بكاميراتها التي
تنصب ترقبا لنتائج وللتصريحات التي
يدلي بها المسؤولون اذا لازلنا عند الرقم
45.70 بالمئه والنتائج تصدر بشكل اولي
ولكن بشكل سريع جدا كما قلت انه هذا اليوم
نسقوا كان سريع جدا ايضا النتائج نسخها
سريع جدا في خلال نحو ساعه عرفنا نتيجه
45.70% من هذه النتائج بانتظار المزيد بعد
قليل ونحن سنبقى في متابعات كل هذه
التفاصيل والاكيد بان هذه القاعه ستكون
قاعه محتشده كذلك بانصار اردوغان وانت
ستكون معهم وسنتابع هذه الكلمه وسنتابع
خاصه الدقائق الاولى التي ستكون قبل
الاعلان عن النتائج في الساعه الساعه
منتصف الليل اعتقد بتوقيت اسطنبول او
بتوقيت تركيا عموما سانتقل الى انقره معك
يا فاطمه فاطمه كيف هي الصوره في انقره
كيف هي توقعات خاصه لان البعض يقول بان
هناك مفاجات قد تحصل وقد تحدث رغم ان
استطلاعات الراي ترجح طرفا على حساب طرف
اخر بين الفتره والاخرى كيف هي تفاصيل من
عندك فاطمه
حقيقه ريم يعني كما ذكر طاهر هناك تراشق
كلامي وهناك يعني دخلنا مرحله او عدنا الى
مرحله عدم اليقين يعني الاجابه لهذا
السؤال تعتمد على من تسالين اما ان سالتي
المعارضه سيقولون لك بانك الجدار اوغلو هو
من يتقدم بالفعل بنسبه 53% فاصله 87 يعني
ايضا غرد قبل قليل قائلا بان نحن في
المقدمه اي هم المعارضه في المقدمه وكان
هناك ايضا مؤتمر صحفي مشترك لرئيس بلديه
اسطنبول اكرم امام اوغلو ورئيس بلديه
انقره منصوري افاش قالوا فيها بانهم
يجددون عدم ثقتهم بوكاله الاناضول او اي
وكالات رسميه بخصوص الانتخابات وانهم
واثقون من ان كما بان كمالك لجار اوغلو هو
من سيفوز في الانتخابات وسيكون الرئيس
الثالث عشر لتركيا بعد قليل سياتي الى مقر
حزب الشعب الجمهوري رؤساء احزاب الطاوله
السياسيه هنا في هذا المقر الذي نت
ليتابعون مجريات الانتخابات ويبدون دعمهم
للمرشح الذين يؤيدونه وهو طبعا
دعيني اتحدث لك بالارقام ريم يعني هنا في
الارقام التي تحدث اشار اليها طاهر لا
تحديثات تذكر ولكن اتحدث عن انقره تحديدا
يعني 45 في المئه فاصله 60 من الصناديق تم
فرزه حتى الان منها
49.70% صوت لرجب طيب اردوغان و43
لصالح
اما اوجان فله 6.70% ومحرم انجي المرشح
المنسحب له
0.5% فقط اذا هذه اخر الارقام واخر
التحديثات على ما يبدو 50% من الصديق
الصناديق في انقره تم فرزها حتى الان ريم
عمليات الفرز مستمره وسنبقى لحظه بلحظه مع
هذا الارقام الى قهرمان مرعش الان مع مفضل
العربي غسان
التفاصيل كذلك من عندك وان كانت هناك
خروقات البعض يتحدث كذلك عن بعض الخروقات
التي لن تؤثر على عمليه الفرز او حتى على
اعداد الاصوات فيما بعد هل رصدت شيئا معين
فيما يخص هذا الموضوع
حتى اللحظه لم نرصد ايه خروقات في كهرمان
مرعش وعلى الاقل في الاماكن التي تجولت
فيها نحن نقف في احد الصناديق الاختراع
هناك سبعه صناديق وكما تشاهدين من خلفي
اغلقت اربعه انتهى الفرس في اربعه صناديق
وبقيه ثلاثه صناديق وهم على وشك الانتهاء
من عمليه الفرز التي بدات منذ ساعتين
تقريبا وما زالت مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه
لكن هناك تفوق للرئيس اردوغان في ولايه
كهرمان مرعش وكان انصار اردوغان وحزب
العداله والتنميه منذ تقريبا ساعه ونصف
يجوبون شوارع المدينه في كهرمان مرعش في
عبر مواكب في سياراتهم يرفعون علم حزب
العداله والتنميه وصور اردوغان ويحتفلون
لا ادري ان كنت تستمعين الان هناك اغاني
واحتفالات في خلفي في هذه الشوارع التي
تحيط بنا الان على اساس ان الرئيس اردوغان
يتصدر في ولايات كهرمان مرعش بالرغم من ان
عمليات الفرز او نسبه الفرز لغايه الان
تجاوزت ال 34% لكن في مرعش يسجل اردوغان
69%.6 مقابل 24% لكلجدار اوغلو وفي عدد من
الولايات الجنوبيه ايضا ريم ما زال
اردوغان يتصدر المشهد والنسب تشير الى
تفوق اردوغان بفرق كبير حقيقه نذكر منها
عنتاب واديمان اورفا عثمانيه كيلس وغيرها
يتصدر فيها اردوغان مقابل منافسه كالجدار
اوغلو وهي عمليا هذه الولايات ريم تاريخيا
كانت تصوت لحزب العداله والتنميه وايضا
للرئيس اردوغان من هؤلاء كهرمان مرعش التي
تدين بالولاء
لاردوغان وايضا حزب العداله والتنميه
وهناك عمليات ما زالت متواصله هذه حتى هذه
اللحظه الارقام قابله للتغيير بالتاكيد
والتبديل بكل تاكيد خلال الساعات المقبله
ربما تتغير هذه الارقام ربما يتقلص الفارق
بين اردوغان ومنافسه كالجدار اوغلو خلال
الساعات المقبله لكن يعني تبقى هذه
الولايات دائما تصوت لحزب العداله
والتنميه ربما نشاهد يعني
او مفاجات نعم صحيح خصوصا ان هناك
كارثه الزلزال التي ضربت الولايات
الجنوبيه وايضا الظرف الاقتصادي وايضا
الحضور السوري للاجئون السوريين في
الولايات الجنوبيه وهناك يعني كما التقينا
في العديد من الناخبين اليوم كان يقال
السوريين صوتوا لك الجدار عنده بغيت الامر
غسان هذه النقاط التي اتيت على ذكرها
سنناقشها وسنناقش كذلك الملفات الاخرى
التي تقدم بها
زملائنا طاهر وفاطمه من سيكون رئيس تركيا
الجديد هذا هو السؤال الرئيسي والاكيد
باننا سنعود لكم زملائي الكرام تباعا في
نشرتنا القادمه
لمحاوله فهم التطورات وللوقوف على جواب
هذا السؤال شكرا جزيلا لكم من اسطنبول
العربيه طاهر بركه من انقره موفضه العربيه
فاطمه فهد ومن قرن مرعش موفد العربيه غسان
ابو اللوز شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات